[Música]
bom dia meu nome é que deve cob
hoje vou apresentar um projeto com o
qual o paulo tenha ganhamos terceiro
lugar a mota comando nacional já disse
eu aposto que ele vai deixar vocês pelo
menos um pouco mais sustentável de como
você entrou aqui hoje
atualmente somos sustentáveis
infelizmente não de acordo com w é
melhor que a organização mundial de
meteorologia 2016 foi recorde em
emissões de gases estufa como o co2
se nós começarmos a fazer algo a
respeito disso
vamos pegar carlos la la no futuro
portanto o objetivo é provar que é
possível não só é ter atitudes
ecologicamente corretas mas também
idéias que podem ser postas em prática
ecologicamente corretas também então por
que não unir o antigo com o novo porque
não unir sua estabilidade com tecnologia
segurança e além de tudo porque é nova
então por que não a primor ar um
projecto o qual você o que você gosta
bastante então no meu caso sou fascinada
bicicletas por que não criar uma
bicicleta inovadora foi meu caso
o projeto consiste basicamente uma
bicicleta feita de bambu então ecológica
com leds e dynamo portanto tecnológico
também
e vale ressaltar que os leds promove uma
visibilidade logo segurança para o
ciclista
agora alguns dados sobre o bambu que foi
a matéria prima projeto é é altamente
sustentável altamente resistente deve
ser colhido em um homem doente um fato
muito interessante quando a maior
brevidade então a água está presente nas
raízes se não seu caule ele deve ser
cozido fazendo com que os açúcares
presentes nele sejam cristalizados
jogando uma resistência prévia
no meu caso para a confecção da
bicicleta que deve ser indenizado no
final do processo é protegendo do
exterior
agora para confecção da bicicleta fez um
curso
porto alegre onde justamente aprendi
como fazer bicicleta de bambu
portanto posso dizer o quão importante
são as junções assunções compostos por
três materiais sustentáveis também duas
fibras uma delas é o cânhamo a outra é o
sisal e para dar liga utilizei a resina
vegetal que é um poliuretano vegetal que
tem algo muito novo e muito mais
sustentável do que a resina epóxi
a justiça também foram os tais materiais
compósitos uma vez que nos reunimos oa
com bt tendo c como produto no caso as
funções de materiais compostos têm como
característica o fato de serem leves e
muito resistente
algumas fotos da confecção da bicicleta
à esquerda estou lhe chamo de ambos à
direita e só aplicando a resina à
esquerda estou colocando os bambus joão
gabaritos foi um processo anterior da na
confecção da bicicleta e na direita a
bicicleta depois de pronto
bom agora os leds os leds são
controlados através de uma placa chamada
no gene mc1r 5266 a porta de programação
então nós fizemos todo um código é então
é com essa placa tem o uruguai faz
possibilita que quando você conecta
acesso à rede gerada por ela você
consegue abrir um web epe
é como se fosse um aplicativo online no
qual você controla as três funções dos
led piscando desligado ou ligado a isso
como eu disse é uma visibilidade que é a
palavra chave
então a briga sistema seguro agora parte
final mas não menos importante é um
dínamo que tem como objetivo transformar
energia cinética em energia do movimento
é da roda energia elétrica
bom nós desenvolvemos decidiram e
objetivo dele é carregar o senhor então
imaginem um adulto ainda para o trabalho
disse que seu de carregar o celular
pronto com a bike de bambu você consegue
carregar o celular em do trabalho também
e sustentavelmente tem bom com
resultados nós tivemos que é sim
possível união antigo com o novo e mais
ainda que pensar sustentável pensar
tecnológico também é
então agora é a vez de vocês e ti todo
nosso todos nós pensarmos assim vamos
ter um mundo muito mais sustentável e
muito melhor
obrigado
[Música]